enora je crois que nora est prête et
nora est ce qu elle m'entend et nora est
ce qu'elle est prête est ce qu'elle est
sur le siège olalala l'allier et nos
rails et enora est-ce que vous
m'entendez j'ai été mieux
ah oui michel jean michel est un homme
mort je vous le dis alors il est sympa
c'est un super mec s'est alors pas tu as
raison enora sanaa est très simple vous
n'allez peut-être pas sauter noir
d'accord je vous le dis ça va se jouer
sur vos connaissances en télévision vous
aimez l'interné mal non je l'aimais je
laime à mourir encore elle alors enora
je vous poser trois questions à chaque
fois vous me donnerez une réponse abcd
pour la première abc abc pour la
deuxième ou bien voilà ce qui restera en
fait comme mèche à chaque fois on fera
brûler la mèche correspondant à votre
réponse si vous ne sautez pas c'est que
c'est la bonne réponse
d'accord si vous sautez c'est que ces
thèmes en voilà mais on ne le saura pas
d'accord voilà ce que tout était prévu
pour que tu sortes aller ce sera sont
pas comme ça ça sera parfaitement
honnête et nora est ce que vous êtes
prêts oui enora musique voici la
première question
enora et vous pouvez jouer également
chez vous #fb sauty acheter inquiète va
pas sauter oui on fait des jeux sur
n'importe quoi enora voici la première
question vous attendez bien mais quatre
propositions et n'aura non facebook et
enora comment s'appelle le singe parlant
qui accompagne dora l'exploratrice dans
toutes ses aventures ça
santiags b babouche c'est parra boots ou
des birkenstock comment s'appelle le
singe qui accompagne dora l'exploratrice
dans toutes ses aventures
santiags mais j'ai pas dans son bois et
laura et nos racines et nous ramènera il
aura eu droit
oui vous voyez un singe qui s'appelle
santiags bas excuse moi c'est ce qui
s'appelle babouche alors à l'eau et toi
c'est quand même pas c'est quand même
pas ma bouche
oh non c'est pas vrai alors il aura un
nom dès le premier je vous laisse une
dernière chance vous dites quoi paraboot
ce nom ce à quoi donc vos dit je crois
qu'il ya un pigeon qui a fait caca sur
la tête
non non c'est berdych veut plus attendre
maintenant vous me donner une réponse et
c'est celle ci du groupe je prendrai ma
bouche ils ont validé paraboot par ap
août
allez vous dites quoi allez vous faites
brûler la mèche
il fait peur lui avec son chalumeau bah
oui c'est lionel excusez moi c'était
peut-être pas le moment de faire une
blague mais bon attends je n'avais rien
que ça c'est flippant en fait ouais pas
si impossible
non mais par contre c'est passé c'est
précisément là ça prend un petit peu top
c'est toujours sympa passe toujours
sympa cette optique on voyait un feu de
cheminée de chez vous à la maison voyez
un petit peu un petit peu voilà c'est
très sympa virus et puis en erreur un
nom mais vous avez déjà vu un seul ce
qui s'appelle santiags baboule c'est pas
tellement non plus l'extase alors ah
c'est bon ça va et l'orage et indulgent
pour la première question vrai c'est
vrai je ne le saurai plus oui d'accord
parce que j'ai des consignes et ont volé
à nous là je peux perdre ta place un
vêtement c'est toi qui peux être éjecté
qu'elles se tiennent bien la voici la
question la deuxième ne dépas bien sûr
dans le public non plus à nous ce que tu
en as envie ça va y en avoir plus haut
personnage s'il vous plaît aidez pas
franchement parce qu'il ya des gros
enjeux en plus je rappelle qu'on joue
pour deux nettoyeurs la cuillère et deux
paires de chaussons magique sleeper j'ai
pas envie que les gens disent que ya de
la magouille
voici la question quelle personnalité va
intégrer l'équipe de fort boyard en
synthétique gens s'ils foutent rien
moundir sébastien chabal au kenji alors
monde végétal chabal chabal chabal
chabal chabal ou un chabal vous bloquez
la réponse je bloque la réponse attendue
attention vous bloquez la réponse enora
on va faire brûler j'aime la mèche
vous dites chabal sébastien à la veille
va intégrer l'équipe de fort boyard et
je suis autant d attention salut mais
attention à tes doigts
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
elle a toutefois rappelé assuré nora
lalalalalala
redescendre à a
ça va doha mais non évidemment que non
elora s'était pas sa balle à face à
vanessa pubertaire c'était moins dur
brava les bras bonus cambrai
ah oui et tout à l'heure tout à l'heure
la prochaine à y aller
la prochaine à y aller ce sera vous
isabelle morini bosc
[Musique]
vous